[Music]
a new crop of athletes headed to the nfl
tonight was night one of the draft a lot
of big names picked up including for our
las vegas raiders
john treach live in studio with more on
who's coming to the silver and black
that's right brian first round draft
picks are starting to think las vegas is
sweet home alabama
in 2019 the silver and black drafted
crimson tide running back josh jacobs in
2020 they nabbed wide receiver henry
ruggs from the same school
this year they drafted a tackle the size
of tuscaloosa
and alex leatherwood roll raiders the
resume
is as prodigious as the pass protector
alex leatherwood was
a captain on national champion alabama
he was their prize left tackle he won
the outland award as the best lineman in
college football now the six foot six
312 pound offensive tackle
is taking his talents to las vegas which
will feel like an alabama fraternity
house
i'll talk to him a little bit but i'm
more than excited for this opportunity
you know what i mean
reuniting with josh jacobs and uh henry
ruggs they
and leicester cotton as well like they
all know what it takes to win
you know what i mean they they know what
it means to be a champion so just like
reuniting them hopefully we can um bring
a super bowl to las vegas